hi everyone i'm dr brian kruger i'm an
associate vice president in research and
development at lab corp and my team has
been leading stars covey to molecular
testing development at labcorp since the
beginning of the pandemic
today i'm going to talk a little bit
about the work that we have been doing
to perform
national pandemic surveillance using
whole genome sequencing
and i want to start out by highlighting
lab corps reach and
as i'm sure many of you know based on
how often
you see our courier vehicles on the
streets labcorp can cast a very wide net
to capture specimens
from all across the country from a
diagnostic testing perspective
this means that we have a very broad
diverse reach into all areas of the
country and from a pandemic surveillance
perspective
this sort of reach puts us in a really
unique position where
we are one of the few places that has
immediate access to the samples required
for tracking this virus
and its variants throughout the country
for sars kobe 2.
we have this access because of the very
hard work that the team did at the
beginning of the pandemic
we are one of the few companies that
recognized the potential need for a high
throughput sars cov2 assay
in january of 2020 and the molecular r d
group began immediate development on a
pcr assay to support detection and
diagnosis
we began this development journey toward
the end of january
we were the first commercial diagnostic
lab to launch an assay on march 5th
we were the first commercial lab to get
fda authorization for testing
and those milestones were followed by
many other firsts including being the
first to receive home collection
approval
and the first to receive direct to
consumer testing approval
what this means is that because of our
success with rolling out and scaling our
own
internally developed pcr based
diagnostic
we had and we still have unparalleled
access to samples that can be used in
real time to track the spread of the
virus
and the emergence of new variants the
the lab corp coveted 19 rt pcr test
was developed as a very high throughput
implementation of this original cdc
assay
which consisted of four reactions with
fam labeled probes
three reactions targeted three different
regions of the nucleocapsid
sequence and the fourth targeted human
rna sp as the internal control
but the original cdc implementation used
a 16 sample per hour
kyogen bio robot for extraction and um
they did detection and a 96 well plate
on the quant studio 7500 dx so it was a
16 sample extraction
into a 24 sample assay which isn't ideal
on the best day but
it also wasn't a protocol that could be
scaled
to address a pandemic so to combat those
obvious throughput issues with that
original cdc assay we
took their primer and probe sequences
and optimize them for detection on the
quant studio 7
in 384 well format and we also validated
three different high throughput
extraction methods that could each
produce a hundred or more extractions
per hour
in the original implementation of the
high throughput four reaction assay
we could process 96 samples in a 384
well plate every hour
but it was immediately obvious to us
that the assay needed to be multiplex so
while we ordered the four reaction fam
level probes we also ordered oligos
with floors that were compatible with
multiplexing
for this we kept the n1 target as fam
but switched the n2 target to yakima
yellow and the rp target to cy5
and after a bit of optimization we
validated the
multiplexed assay and submitted it for
authorization
which we received from the fda on april
14th
about a month after we received the
initial authorization for the lower
throughput for reaction version of the
assay
all of the assays were automated on
hamilton star liquid handlers and
conversion to the multiplex quadruple
the hourly throughput
of that instrument from 288 samples per
hour
to 1152 samples per hour per instrument
more than half of labcorp's pcr testing
is done
on the fda authorized multiplex assay
and that's really important for this
story because
without the spoke pcr testing process
we would not have been able to quickly
and efficiently scale the sequencing
process
to date more than 30 million pcr tests
have been performed across all
methods so even if just over half of
those tests are on the multiplex pcr
assay we have access to really an
unprecedented number of samples for
performing
surveillance activities and this story
wouldn't be complete without
talking about the supply chains
constraints that were
uh needed to that we needed to overcome
the molecular r d group
validated no less than three consumables
or
methods for every step of this process
this includes
plastic plates tips enzymes extraction
reagents collection devices swabs
if you can think of any consumable that
goes into
any test that is performed we have a
backup validated for the backups backup
and this was essential for our success
in pcr testing
because if you run out of even one of
these consumables you
lose the ability to test samples you
can't provide results
you lose customers and ultimately you
then don't have samples
available for sequencing and i'm really
proud to know that
we were one of the few national
diagnostic testing companies to not
exceed more than a three-day average
turnaround time for pcr testing during
the pandemic
and that's because of supply chain
preparedness and because we developed
our own internal
assay to perform pcr testing using
materials that we can source from
multiple other vendors so i just said a
bunch of words about pcr testing and
supply chain
shortage mitigation strategies for
diagnostic testing and i told you that
we were successful
but here's what i said visually the two
animations here track all the positive
pcr samples that we have seen in our
network
since the pandemic began the map on the
left is a cumulative display of all the
pcr positives and the map on the right
is a
visualization of the positives and
two-week intervals
this map on the right is a really good
estimation of
the dynamics of the virus since
infection lasts about two weeks this map
allows us to see how
the virus is spread throughout the
country now this view only shows us
where the positives are
and as we all know it's not just
important to know where the positives
are but we also need to know
where all the different versions of the
virus are because that determines how we
respond to the emergence of newer
deadlier variants of the virus
but in order for us to know where those
variants are we need an
assay that actually tests for those
variants and the labcorp pcr
test detects two regions of the sars
kovi 2
virus this only provides us with a yes
or a no answer
about whether the virus is present in a
sample it does not tell us anything
about the mutations in the virus or
which version of sars kobe 2
has been detected for that we need to do
genome sequencing
the pcr test detects two small regions
within the viral
genome and these regions provide the
instructions for making the n
protein which can be seen here inside of
the viral particle protecting the viral
genome from
from degradation the viral genome
contains
obviously more information than just the
code for
the n-protein and it's the sequence of
the whole genome that we're interested
in
for tracking how the virus spreads but
as i said it's the pcr testing that
allows us to do the genome sequencing
we receive raw sample in the lab we
isolate the genetic material the virus
put those samples on a plate and then
detect whether or not the virus is
present in the sample by pcr
the genomic surveillance process
leverages the vcr process
because we're able to collect those
leftover samples and pick out all of the
positive samples for whole genome
sequencing we don't have to re-extract
samples
we don't have to pry a primary tube out
of the cobalt hologic system
and everything is nicely organized in a
barcoded plate
those condensed positive plates then
make their way into the whole genome
sequencing process
i'll get into this in a little bit more
detail but the whole genome process
converts the entire
viral genome into something that we can
detect using a genome sequencer
to then identify the specific versions
of the sars cov2 virus present in each
positive sample
and then we associate those viruses with
the position that they fall in within
the viral family tree
the sequencing protocol is one that we
co-developed over many months in
collaboration with pacific biosciences
it's
loosely based off of the protocol mickey
free developed for oxford and
the oxford nanocore system and you can
see the citation for that paper
i'm here in the bottom right hand corner
but
the enzymes and primer concentrations of
that protocol
were optimized for pack bio along with
some modifications to the barcodes to
make them
uh amenable to the circular consensus
sequencing that's used
in the hi-fi platform for pacific
biosciences
the protocol itself is very
straightforward we start out
by creating cdna from residual pcr
testing material
amplify that material using two pools of
non-overlapping m13 tailed
primer pairs those pools are then
asymmetrically barcoded using m13 tags
and pooled for smart bell preparation
sequencing then proceeds on the sql 2
using a 20 hour movie for the data
collection portion
and this process has been fully
automated on
hamilton liquid handlers and we have
released the exact protocol that we use
for doing this on the pack bio website
so
if you're interested in running this
protocol on your own sql or sql 2
please stop by the pacific biosciences
website and you'll be able to
download the protocol there hi-fi yield
on the sql 2 has been
really impressive we're able to load to
a p1 of 70
without failing runs with a mean read
length of thirty thousand
or thirty seven thousand uh faces and a
mean
sub read length of thirty six hundred
bases
um we're seeing um loading very
coming across very consistently in the
60 to 70 percent range which
um helps a lot when we're putting about
800 samples on each run
using this method we can get whole
genome coverage from approximately 60
of the samples with a ct of less than 27
or we can get lineage coverage from
about 80 percent of the samples less
than 30 ct
that's really the only major trade-off
between pack bio and short read
approaches to get these long reads
you need high quality starting material
i've also included an
example here of the run metrics with a
waterfall plot to show
where we see performance drop off and
and highlight that for surveillance we
are sequencing samples
up to a ct of 30. but performance
appears to
seriously degrade around 27 ct
there are a number of optimizations that
are in the pipeline to try to recover
data from these samples above 27 ct
however the majority
of this effect is is due to the
availability of target capable of
producing long raids
for sequencing on the sql 2. so
we do have a new protocol on development
to increase
yield from these higher ct samples
utilizing
600 base pair reads and
preliminary results with that protocol
are very encouraging
but we can't talk about biosequencing
without
highlighting the advantages of long
reads
in variant detection and phasing and as
you can see here the
1200 base pair amplicons that we're
using allow us to phase variance within
samples where coverage is high enough to
do so
um this could be used in the future to
identify
interesting low frequency subtypes that
occur within individuals and potentially
discover
early novel variant strains as they
emerge
in addition to that minor varying and
phasing
we can also use long reads to capture
large deletions that exceed the maximum
insert size of short read approaches and
here you can see deletions in two
samples that would have been mostly
missed by
the short read single tile amplicon
approach
the pipeline that we've set up for
processing is also pretty standardized
we take the pac-bio-generated ccs reads
into alignment and variant calling
for this we use clc but there are other
tools like minimap and juliet that
work just as well one of the major
problems that we ran into with
generating consensus sequences
was that there really weren't any great
tools for doing this that didn't
introduce frame shifts into the
consensus
so once again we co-developed a method
with pac bio to solve this problem
and this is work that was spearheaded
mostly by liz
sang at pac bio along with lax ire and
chen zhang at labcorp who developed a
program called the vcf cons
to generate these consensus sequences
from a vcf file based on
read depth by replacing missing sequence
in the reference with ends and
inserting variants with greater than 50
frequency into the reference
and this completely eliminated the frame
shift effect that we saw with the
the more traditional uh methods for
performing consensus sequence generation
vcf cons has been
published and it's a another joint
pre-print from
pac biome lab corp and the code for it
is also available on github
for the rest of the pipeline clade calls
are made with next glade lineage calls
are made with pangolin
and all of the raw data and metadata and
consensus information is assembled and
packaged for delivery to the cdc
but that pipeline wasn't generated
overnight and the genome sequencing work
originally started
as an internal research and development
project we recognized early on
that we were going to have a centralized
location for collecting positive samples
and began as we
as soon as we possibly could to save
these samples in the r d freezers
and it was clear to us that no one had
the same access to positive samples that
we did
and that we could play a really critical
role in understanding how the pandemic
began
so every day we would go into the lab
and steal all of the plates and primary
tubes that were going to be thrown away
and
at the end of the day we picked out all
of the
the positive samples for archive we did
all of this at the same time that we
were
developing the pcr testing
infrastructure that is
now used to support over half of the
sars cov2 testing at labcorp
and we spent most of the summer
developing the sequencing protocol in
our
spare time and then we sequenced 10 000
of these early
positive samples between september and
november of 2020.
on december 7th dr michael levandoski
presented the results
of the early sequencing work at the asm
microbial ngs conference
and then in that presentation he
highlighted this model that we had
developed for doing national genomic
surveillance and on december 27th
we were awarded a cdc contract to
continue doing this work on a national
level
in real time we were awarded that
contract because of the data we had
generated
here you can see the sars kobe 2 genome
on the bottom of the graph and the bars
you see growing
and the animation are the number of
mutations we detected at those positions
of the genome of the virus over the
course of our surveillance study
these mutations matter a lot with
respect to how the virus functions and
its ability to infect the host
evade the immune system or even thought
treatments that
we've developed to combat it and i want
to draw your
attention to one mutation in particular
we've all heard about spike protein
mutations and
here i'm highlighting the d614g mutation
everyone
almost call probably knows that this is
an important variant but it became the
most important variant in the us
much sooner than most people realize and
that's because it spread across the
country
during a time when there was very little
surveillance going on at all and it's
this data that we use to support our
engagement with cdc
to expand this uh internal surveillance
project
to a national one and it's these types
of mutations like d614g and the spike
protein
that we're all interested in because
they're cool scientifically but more
importantly
because it's mutations like this that
drive our response and guide vaccine
and therapeutic development and that's
because it's the spike protein
that the virus uses to enter cells and
it's these spike mutants that make the
new viruses a little bit scarier we've
heard about
b117 that originated in the uk p1 that
originated in brazil
and b.1.351 that originated in south
africa
the mutations in these viruses make them
more transmissible
but the mutations in the spike protein
in particular the region of the spike
protein known as the receptor binding
domain
or rbd are the most worrisome because
it's
this region of the virus that our immune
system recognizes to fight off the virus
and it is feared that mutations and the
spike protein will make the vaccines we
develop less effective because the virus
might change
so much that our immune system might not
be able to recognize the virus anymore
and unfortunately we've seen evidence of
this already and the main takeaway from
the graphs
here are that the immune response to
either b117 or b
1 351 or reduced significantly in people
previously infected with sars cov2
and the immune response to both of these
new viral strains is also reduced and
people vaccinated with the new mrna
vaccines
but it's important to note that the
vaccines still appear to be effective
but i think this is illustrative of why
pandemic surveillance is so important
we need to be able to detect these new
variants in order for us to plan
for how to defeat them and the work that
aids in the
preparation of our response to variants
consists of us sequencing
many thousands of samples a week we at
lab corp have been tasked with
sequencing a subset of those thousands
as a part of
cdc's baseline study this allows us to
help the cdc track the
individual viruses they spread across
the u.s and those results are presented
on
the weekly cdc spheres calls to do this
we
centrally collect thousands of sample
plates a week in north carolina condense
them into the positive plates
and sequence the genomes of those
randomly selected positive samples
but what what does this look like in
practice um
this map here um this animated map shows
where the
positives we're picking come from and
the intensity of the states represent
how many positives
we pulled from those states relative to
the others and
the animation ends on the cumulative
total
that we've sequenced so far within
the cdc project
we can also generate clay doughnut
charts to show how the prevalence of
each clade has or hasn't changed in the
entire data set
at the state level obviously there are
some sample size effects here but it's
still interesting
to visualize and a few interesting
things have appeared in the last few
months especially relating to trends of
the variance of concern in some states
and a good example of this is the
evolution of the clade distribution in
florida
which is having a significant outbreak
of the b.117 variant also known
and listed here as 20i 501y
v1 you can see that variant approaching
about
25 of the samples that we see every week
out of florida
but you might be asking yourself what
the work we've done has actually made an
impact and
i think the answer to that question
would be yes it was a lab corp
sequencing surveillance efforts that
detected the first case of the south
african variant in the u.s
proving that we're able to detect things
when we look for them and
we can have an impact on our ability to
combat the virus by
providing information to state and
federal teams as they respond
to the emergence of these new variants
and this isn't the only set of
first cases we've detected after
detecting the 351 variant in south
carolina cdc asked us to focus our
sequencing efforts geographically
and again this proves out the power of
the system we've developed
and the enormous reach that we have
nationally cdc asked us to concentrate
picking to the southeast so we did
and increased sampling across the
southeast from about 100 samples per
state
to an average of about 300.
um and that sampling paid off because we
picked up five
more um 351 samples that week
and then that set we picked up two that
were newly discovered in virginia
and and in illinois following that
focused effort
we have since returned to unbiased
sampling across the u.s and
have seen an increase in the cases of
both b.117 and b.351
obviously the denominator matters here
but this is a
good early evidence that pandemic
surveillance does
actually allow us to capture variants as
they spread across the u.s
more recently there have been reports of
a new variant of
b.1.526 that was first identified in new
york
this variant uh includes the e484 k
spike mutation which
resides in the receptor binding domain
um then we saw the first of
these cases on february 6th in new york
and connecticut
and over the next two weeks we saw the
case load increase to about 179
primarily in the northeast with a few
emerging in the southeast in north
carolina and georgia
b.1.526 now represents about 10 to 20
percent of the cases that we're seeing
come out of new york and new jersey
and watching variants like this through
genomic surveillance is important
um and hopefully with the renewed
interest in
and science-based policy we and others
are are further enabled to continue this
work and
sequencing thousands of samples a week
and
and 526 itself represents an interesting
case because new york and new jersey had
a
pretty big outbreak of stars kobe 2
back around this time last year so the
the idea would be that they have built
up a reasonable
amount of population immunity and it
appears that
this virus doesn't really care about
that um
but one of the most important aspects of
the
labcorp data set is that it's based on
random sampling unlike other sequencing
initiatives that target sequencing
samples that they believe are variants
of concern we sequence samples randomly
across the nation
this limits the level of sampling bias
in our data set although there
are still states that we end up sampling
more than others
but generally this data set is much less
targeted than other initiatives
because of this we can look at national
trends and the distribution of clades
across the country
the dominant clade throughout our
sampling has been 20g
which is the major u.s clade that was
described early on in the pandemic
in the united states but as you can see
here in the last few weeks the
prevalence of 20g
has been reduced while 20i501y.v1 which
is b.117
and clade 20b are seeing a bit of an
uptick
indicating that the other two clades may
be out competing 20g
potentially a little or too early to to
say that but that that looks like that's
where the the
the trend is going um and this trend um
for b117 is
also in agreement with early predictions
that this variant would become the
major u.s variant by by the beginning to
the end of march
so i hope that this presentation has
helped convince you
of the importance of genomic
surveillance during a pandemic
sequencing based surveillance allows us
to know the things that we don't know
uh we've deposited over 15 000 sequences
and you say it over the
past nine weeks in collaboration with
cdc combined with the work of other
state labs and universities
approximately 10 000 new sequences are
making it into the databases every week
and and with that we're finally now
getting the data and the tools we need
to respond to this pandemic with a
reasoned scientific approach and here
i'm showing a
a headline from a bastion of
scientific integrity the new york post
and the headline might border on
fear-mongering but this is really what
we're up against
we're doing surveillance to try to
discover harmful variants
before they reach community spread and
allow us to prepare for how to respond
to these
viruses socially and therapeutically
but obviously this this work doesn't
happen in a vacuum an incredible number
of people across
labcorp have supported this work with
far too many to name here but a huge
thanks goes out to all the operations
teams corporate it teams
and lab directors that have supported
this work
for the last year and who now continue
to support the deployment and scaling of
it
on the development side i need to thank
my team our informatics group
and the pack bio team the majority of
the picking and archiving work
along with the high level analysis was
done by dr mike levandoski
scott parker and john pruitt optimized
the wet lab process
for the sequencing protocol kim wagner
developed all the automation not only
the sequencing automation but the
automation that has
supported tens of millions of pcr
results ayla burns performed
all the wet lab rt-pcr work that led to
the countless fda approvals and
authorizations for testing
all the way from the original submission
through to pooling heat extraction
asymptomatic testing home collection
and validation of nearly every plastic
consumable known to science
stan litovsky and his team at the center
for bioinformatics developed the
analysis pipelines in conjunction with
pacific biosciences
and a special thanks really needs to go
out to
lax ire and chen zhang who have for many
weeks been shepherding samples through a
not so
automated analysis pipeline and finally
additional special thanks to
liz sang george ewan andy larea
and and the rest of the pack bio team
and of course duncan mcconnell
uh dewani bacha and scott sammons at the
cdc
who have all put up with our antics for
the the past
year with that i'm happy to take any
questions that
you might have please contact me by
email or
search me out on social media thank you
you